tonight we look at the future of
self-driving vehicles would you get into
one well many people believe autonomous
cars are coming and soon but there are
definitely safety issues that could put
on the brakes correspondent Brian Yanis
reports tonight from Pittsburgh whether
it's picking up customers in Las Vegas
or delivering a pizza in Michigan or
Miami today driverless vehicles are
being tested seemingly everywhere in
fact at least 40 cities in the u.s. are
testing autonomous vehicles who are
committed to doing so at Carnegie
Mellon's robotics lab engineers have
partnered with General Motors we
actually have radar behind the logo this
2011 Cadillac SRX drives autonomously
but with a human test driver on board
and along specific city routes the
ultimate goal is to create the world's
first fully autonomous vehicle that
drives itself anywhere in any conditions
it's going to take at least my estimate
8 to 10 years before we likely reach
full automation and the race to be first
is well underway
General Motors plans to launch
self-driving Robo taxis with no steering
wheels or pedals in US cities by 2019 GM
is in a dead heat with self-driving
company way mo way Mo's driverless cars
have driven over five million miles
through two dozen cities the Google
offshoot will launch a ride-sharing
service this year but there are new
concerns about safety
uber has suspended driverless car
testing after its self-driving vehicle
hit and killed a woman on March 18th in
Tempe Arizona the company is now being
accused of compromising safety in an
effort to catch up with leading
competitors like way mo in accusation it
denies maybe now is the time to rethink
about how how uber works in the city and
how it tests its vehicles here Michael
Lam is Pittsburgh city controller uber
started testing its autonomous vehicles
there in 2016 he admits his city hastily
welcomed uber under the handshake
promise of a partnership which he says
is one-sided we've opened the city to
them allowed them to test their vehicles
here
are out now collecting a lot of data if
bruh can monetize that data shutting the
city benefit from that monetization 22
states have enacted autonomous vehicle
legislation so far as government tries
to catch up with an industry in the fast
lane inclement weather poses a big
hurdle for autonomous vehicles heavy
rain for instance makes it difficult for
car sensors to pick up objects still
rethink X an independent think-tank
predicts by 2030 95 percent of the miles
traveled in the US will be in
self-driving cars Shanon Wow all right
Brian Janis in Pittsburgh thank you